maligayang pagbabalik sa pag-unawa sa Quantum na impormasyon at kompyutasyon ang pangalan ko ay John Watus at ako ang teknikal na direktor para sa edukasyon sa IBM
Quantum ito ang aralin bilang 14 ng seryeng ito at ito ang ikalawang aralin ng ikaapat na yunit na tungkol sa Quantum error
correction sa nakaraang aralin ay unang tiningnan natin ang Quantum error correction kasama na ang nine qubit Shore code na nagpapatunay na
posible ang Quantum error correction sa teorya tinalakay din natin ang discretization ng mga error na nagbibigay-daan sa atin
na itama ang mga arbitrary na Quantum error sa mga qubit sa pamamagitan ng epektibong pag-project sa mga ito sa bit flips at phase
flips sa araling ito tatalakayin natin ang stabilizer formalism na isang mathematical na kasangkapan kung saan maaari nating
tukuyin at suriin ang isang malawak na klase ng quantum error correcting codes na kilala bilang stabilizer codes kasama na dito ang 9 qubit Shore
code kasama ang maraming iba pang halimbawa kabilang ang mga code na malamang na mas angkop sa tunay na mundo ng Quantum
computing devices kaysa sa Shore code hindi lahat ng Quantum error correcting code ay stabilizer code ngunit marami ang ganoon
kasama na ang bawat halimbawa na makikita natin sa seryeng ito may tiyak na mga kawili-wili at potensyal na kapaki-pakinabang na Quantum error
correcting codes na hindi stabilizer codes ngunit ang mga ito ay medyo mas kumplikado at sa anumang kaso wala namang
tanong na ang stabilizer formalism ay isang cornerstone sa pundasyon ng quantum error correction at ito ay
lubos na maaasahan sa natitirang bahagi ng yunit narito ang isang maikling pangkalahatang-ideya ng aralin magsisimula tayo sa maikling talakayan
ng mga Pauli matrix at tensor products ng mga Pauli matrix na maaaring kumatawan sa mga operasyon sa mga qubit gayundin sa
mga sukat ng mga qubit tulad ng aking ipapaliwanag at sa kontekstong ito madalas nating tinutukoy ang mga ito bilang mga observable pagkatapos ay babalik tayo at
muling titingnan ang repetition code at makikita natin kung paano natin ito malarawan sa pamamagitan ng mga Pauli operasyon at observable at iyon ay magiging kapwa nagbibigay-impormasyon
at hahantong sa isang pangkalahatang talakayan ng mga stabilizer code kasama ang ilang halimbawa at mga pangunahing katangian ng stabilizer
codes at kung paano natin isasagawa ang mga pangunahing gawain ng pag-encode pag-detect ng mga error at pagwawasto ng mga
error magsisimula tayo ng aralin sa maikling talakayan ng mga Pauli operasyon pangunahin upang maihanda ang entablado para sa
stabilizer formalism ngunit pati na rin upang maobserbahan ang ilang mahahalagang katotohanan at magtakda ng ilang pangunahing terminolohiya una narito ang mga Pauli
matrix kasama ang 2x2 identity Matrix pati na rin ang tatlong non-identity Pauli matrix na ibibigay ng pangalan
capital X X Y at Z sa natitirang bahagi ng serye ang lahat ng apat na matrix na ito ay parehong unitary at Hermitian at maaari nating
kilalanin ang mga ito sa mga operasyon sa isang qubit kasama ang mga operasyon na maaari nating isagawa pati na rin ang mga error tulad ng
tinalakay sa nakaraang aralin ang mga non-identity Pauli matrix X Y at Z ay nagtatago ng isa't isa
ibig sabihin ang XY ay katumbas ng -1 * YX ang XZ ay katumbas ng negatibong ZX at ang YZ ay katumbas
ng negatibong ZY at madali mong masusuri ang mga relasyong ito sa pamamagitan ng pagsasagawa ng mga multiplikasyon ang mga anti-commutation
relations na ito ay napakasimple ngunit napakahalaga sa stabilizer formalism at sa ibang lugar at partikular na
tulad ng makikita natin ang mga minus sign na lumalabas kapag pinagpalit natin ang pagkakasunod-sunod ng dalawang magkaibang non-identity Pauli matrix sa isang produkto ay naaayon nang eksakto sa
pag-detect ng mga error sa stabilizer formalism mayroon din tayong mga multiplication rule na nakalista dito ang bawat isa
Pauli matrix ay sariling inverse nito na naaayon sa katotohanang parehong unitary at Hermitian ang mga ito at kung i-multiply mo ang anumang dalawang magkaibang non-identity
Pauli matrix palagi kang makakakuha ng plus o minus I times ang natitirang non-identity
Pauli matrix sa partikular hanggang sa isang global phase ang Y ay katumbas ng X times Z na nagpapaliwanag ng ating focus sa x at z errors sa
Quantum error correction ang X ay kumakatawan sa isang bit flip ang Z ay kumakatawan sa isang phase flip at kaya hanggang sa isang global phase ang Y ay kumakatawan
sa parehong mga error na nagaganap sa parehong qubit ang apat na matrix na ito ay lahat kumakatawan
sa mga operasyon o error o kawalan ng error sa isang qubit ngunit madalas na maginhawa ang pagtitensor ng mga ito nang magkasama
upang magsagawa ng mga operasyon o error sa maraming qubit bilang isang terminolohiya tuwing tinutukoy natin ang isang N qubit Pauli
operasyon ang ibig sabihin natin ay isang tensor product ng anumang n Pauli matrix tulad ng mga halimbawang ipinapakita
dito karaniwan ding gamitin ang terminong Pauli operasyon kapag mayroon ditong global phase ngunit upang panatilihing simple ang lahat hangga't maaari
gagamitin ko ang terminong Pauli operasyon na ibig sabihin ay simpleng tensor product ng mga Pauli matrix ang weight ng isang N qubit Pauli
operasyon ay simpleng bilang ng mga non-identity Pauli matrix sa tensor product halimbawa ang n-fold tensor
product ng 2 x dalawang identity Matrix sa sarili nito ay isang weight zero Pauli operasyon ang isang tensor product ng dalawang Pauli X
matrix at isang grupo ng mga identity matrix ay may weight na dalawa at iba pa kung tutuusin ang weight ng isang N
qubit Pauli operasyon ay ang bilang ng mga qubit kung saan ito kumikilos nang hindi-trivially at karaniwang ang mga Quantum error correcting code ay
idinisenyo upang makita at maitama ang mga error na kinakatawan ng mga Pauli operasyon hanggang sa isang tiyak na weight maaari nating
isipin ang mga Pauli operasyon sa iba't ibang paraan kasama na bilang mga operasyong sadyang ginagawa ng mga Quantum gate pati na rin
bilang mga error at makikita rin natin sa lalong madaling panahon na ang mga Pauli operasyon ay maaaring maglarawan ng mga sukat minsan ay kapaki-pakinabang din
ang pag-iisip tungkol sa mga Pauli operasyon bilang mga generator ng ilang mga set sa algebraic na kahulugan na maaaring makilala mo
kung pamilyar ka sa group theory kung hindi ka pamilyar sa group theory okay lang iyon hindi talaga ito mahalaga
para sa araling ito ngunit kung interesado kang pag-aralan ang Quantum error correction nang mas malalim maaari mong matuklasan na ang ilang
pangunahing group theory ay napakatulong para doon sa anumang kaso ipagpalagay nating P1 hanggang PR ay mga N qubit Pauli operasyon
kaya ang P1 ay isang N qubit Pauli operasyon ang P2 ay isang N qubit Pauli operasyon at iba pa kapag tinutukoy natin ang set na nabuo ng
P1 hanggang Pr ang ibig sabihin natin ay ang set ng lahat ng matrix na maaari nating makuha sa pamamagitan ng pagpaparami ng mga matrix na ito nang magkasama sa
anumang kombinasyon at sa anumang pagkakasunod-sunod na piliin natin kinukuha ang bawat isa nang maraming beses hangga't gusto natin makikita natin ang ilang halimbawa sa lalong madaling
panahon ngunit una hayaan akong banggitin ang notasyon na ginagamit natin upang tukuyin ang set na ito ang set na nabuo ng P1 hanggang Pr at
ito ay P1 hanggang Pr na pinaghihiwalay ng mga kuwit sa loob ng mga angled bracket medyo mukhang madali nating malito
ang notasyong ito sa direktang notasyon ngunit hindi iyon karaniwang nangyayari at ito ang tradisyonal na notasyon sa group
theory narito ang isang halimbawa ng set na nabuo ng X Y at Z kaya ang n ay katumbas ng isa sa halimbawang ito dahil walang
tensor products at kinukuha natin ang lahat ng tatlong non-identity Pauli matrix bilang mga generator lumalabas na may
16 na matrix na maaaring mabuo sa pamamagitan ng pagbuo ng mga produkto na kinabibilangan ng tatlong matrix na ito at maaari mong paghiwatiin ito
sa pamamagitan ng mga multiplication rule na nakita natin kanina partikular na maaari siyempre makuha natin ang X Y at Z pati na rin ang identity
at sa katunayan maaari rin nating makuha ang alinman sa apat na matrix na ito times I 1 o negatibong I at iyon ang
lahat ang set na ito ay karaniwang kilala bilang ang Pauli group maaari rin nating isaalang-alang ang set na
nabuo ng x at z lamang at makukuha natin ang kalahati ng Pauli group sa kasong ito
at isang panghuling halimbawa kahit man lang sa ngayon maaari nating isaalang-alang ang set na nabuo ng X tensor x at z tensor Z kaya ang n ay katumbas ng
dalawa sa kasong ito at makakakuha tayo ng apat na elemento lamang sa pagkakataong ito dahil ang X tensor x at z tensor Z
ay nagko-commute sa isa't isa ang mga Pauli matrix at ang mga N qubit Pauli operasyon sa mas pangkalahatang paraan ay naglalarawan
ng mga unitary na operasyon maging ito ay mga error o sadyang ginagawa ngunit naglalarawan din sila
ng mga sukat upang maging mas tiyak simula sa tatlong non-identity Pauli matrix maaari nating iugnay ang bawat isa sa mga
matrix na ito sa isang projective measurement na tinukoy sa pamamagitan ng mga eigenvalue at eigenvector nito at narito sa screen
ay may mga spectral decomposition ng mga matrix na ito na makakatulong na linawin ito sa esensya kapag tinutukoy natin ang isang X
sukat ang isang Y sukat o isang Z sukat ang ibig natin ay ang projective measurement na tinukoy ng mga projection
sa mga eigenspace ng mga matrix na ito at karaniwan nating iniisip ang mga eigenvalue bilang mga kaukulang
resulta ng sukat halimbawa ang isang X sukat ay isang sukat na may kinalaman sa plus
minus basis ng isang qubit o bilang kahalili maaari nating ilarawan ito sa pamamagitan ng set na naglalaman ng mga projection ket plus bra plus at ket
minus bra minus ang isang Z sukat sa kabilang banda ay wala nang iba kundi isang standard basis
sukat bagaman tulad ng sinabi ko minsan ay kinikilala natin ang mga eigenvalue sa mga resulta ng sukat at kung gagawin natin iyon
ang mga resulta ay plus at minus isa kumpara sa 0 at isa ayon sa pagkakasunod-sunod maaari naming gawin ang isang bagay
sa ganitong paraan para sa mga arbitrary Hermitian matrix at ang terminong observable ay karaniwang ginagamit sa sitwasyong ito para sa mga Pauli
matrix at N qubit Pauli operasyon sa mas pangkalahatang paraan maaari nating isagawa ang mga ganitong sukat nang hindi nakakapinsala gamit ang
phase estimation at para lamang masiguro na malinaw ang diagram na ito dito ay nagsasagawa tayo ng mga sukat nang hindi nakakapinsala sa
itaas na qubit samantalang ang ibabang qubit ay palaging ini-initialize sa isang plus state o sa madaling salita ay isang Hadamard na inilapat sa isang
zero state dahil iyon ang paraan ng pagtatrabaho ng phase estimation pansinin na dahil ang mga eigenvalue
ay plus isa at minus isa lamang sa kasong ito kailangan natin ng isang control qubit lamang na siyang ibabang qubit sa diagram na
ito ang higit pa rito ay isang aksaya lamang dahil mayroon lamang isang bit ng katumpakan na kailangan pag-isipan ang eigenvalue
ay alinman sa plus isa o minus isa at ang sukat ay perpekto na tulad nito ang resulta ng sukat na ito
sa paraan ng standard basis measurement sa circuit ay magiging zero para sa plus isa na eigenvalue outcome
na naaayon sa plus state sa kaso ng isang X observable at ang resulta ay isa para sa minus isa na eigenvalue
o ang minus state sa kasong ito ang lahat ng sinabi ko ay natural na lumalawak sa N qubit Pauli operasyon
sa kondisyon na nasa isip natin na kapag nag-iisip tayo tungkol sa isang observable ay sinusukat natin ang mga eigenvalue
hindi sumusukat na may kinalaman sa isang basis ng mga eigenvector halimbawa isaalang-alang ang dalawang
qubit Pauli operasyon Z tensor Z muli mayroon lamang dalawang eigenvalue plus isa at minus isa kaya ang
sukat ay inilarawan ng dalawang projection pansinin sa partikular na ang sukat na iniuugnay natin sa
observable na ito ay hindi kapareho ng pagsukat sa parehong qubit gamit ang isang Z sukat o sa madaling salita ay isang standard basis measurement kundi ito ay isang dalawang
resulta na projective measurement kung saan ang mga projection ay nasa mga espasyong sinaklaw ng lahat ng mga eigenvector na naaayon sa
bawat isa sa dalawang eigenvalue plus isa at minus isa ang isa pang paraan ng pag-iisip tungkol dito ay ang mga eigenvalue ng isang tensor
product ay mga produkto ng mga eigenvalue ng mga indibidwal na matrix na kinukuha natin ang tensor product at
dahil ang negatibo 1 * negatibo 1 ay kapareho ng positibong 1 * positibong 1 halimbawa ang sukat na ito ay hindi
nakakikilala sa pagitan ng 0 0 at 1 1 kaya kung susukat tayo halimbawa ng isang phi plus Bell state gamit ang sukat
na inilarawan ng observable na ito ay tiyak na makukuha natin ang resulta na naaayon sa eigenvalue Plus isa
at ang estado ay mananatiling hindi nagbago kumpara sa pag-collapse sa 0 0 o 1 1 na magiging mangyayari kung
isasagawa natin ang standard basis measurements sa dalawang qubit kaya ang isang Z tensor Z sukat ay hindi
kapareho ng pagsasagawa ng dalawang Z sukat nang hiwalay ngunit maaari nating isagawa ang mga ganitong sukat gamit ang phase
estimation sa parehong paraan tulad ng dati gamit ang isang control qubit tulad ng ipinapakita sa circuit diagram na
naglalageneralize sa anumang N qubit Pauli operasyon kapalit ng Z tensor Z kapag mayroon lamang tayong Z Pauli matrix
maaari nating gawing simple ang circuit tulad nito at ang inihahayag nito na maliwanag din mula sa mga projection na nagtatakda
ng sukat ay na ang pagsasagawa ng isang Z tensor Z sukat sa dalawang qubit ay katumbas ng pagsukat ng kanilang parity
sa pamamagitan ng pag-iisip sa mga tuntunin ng standard basis at ito ay naglalageneralize sa tensor product ng anumang bilang ng Pauli Z
matrix susunod ay muling titingnan natin ang three-bit repetition code sa pagkakataong ito inilalagay ito sa mga tuntunin ng Pauli
operasyon ito ang magiging una nating medyo simpleng halimbawa ng isang stabilizer code at tatalakayin natin kung paano pangkalahatanin ito
sa lalong madaling panahon ngunit kapaki-pakinabang na makita kung paano ito gumagana sa simpleng kasong ito muna alalahanin na kapag inilapat natin ang
3-bit repetition code sa mga qubit ini-encode natin ang isang ibinigay na qubit state Alpha 0 plus beta 1 bilang Alpha 000 plus beta 111
at ibibigay natin sa three qubit encoding na ito ang pangalang Psi para sa kaginhawaan kaya sa kahulugan ang S ay isang valid na tatlong qubit
encoding ng isang qubit state ngunit kung nais nating suriin ito sapat na suriin na ang sumusunod na dalawang equation ay totoo ang
unang equation ay nagsasabing ang paglapat ng Z operasyon sa pinakakaliwa na dalawang qubit ng S ay walang ginagawa sa S na ibig sabihin
ang S ay isang eigenvector ng Z tensor Z tensor Identity o Z Z identity lamang para sa maikling pangalan na may eigenvalue na isa at ang pangalawa
equation ay katulad maliban na ang mga Z operasyon ay inilapat sa pinaka-kanan na dalawang qubit ang ideya ay kung iniisip natin ang S
bilang linear combination ng mga standard basis state kung gayon ang unang equation ay nagpapahiwatig na maaari lamang tayong magkaroon ng hindi-zero na koepisyente para sa mga standard basis state
kung saan ang pinakakaliwa na dalawang bit ay may even parity o katumbas nito ay magkapantay at ang pangalawang equation ay nagpapahiwatig na maaari lamang
tayong magkaroon ng hindi-zero na koepisyente para sa mga standard basis state kung saan ang pinaka-kanan na dalawang bit ay may even parity ang isa pang paraan ng pag-iisip tungkol dito
ay ang pagtingin sa dalawang Pauli operasyong ito bilang mga observable at kung susukat tayo ng dalawang observable na ito gamit ang
simpleng circuit na binanggit ko kanina ay tiyak na makakakuha tayo ng resulta ng sukat na naaayon sa plus isa na eigenvalue
dahil ang S ay isang eigenvector ng parehong observable na may eigenvalue na isa ngunit ang simpleng bersyon na ito ng pinagsanib
circuit para sa hiwalay na pagsukat ng mga observable ay wala nang iba kundi ang ating parity check circuit para sa 3-bit
repetition code at kaya nakikita natin na ang ating dalawang equation nang magkasama ay katumbas ng parity check circuit na nagbibigay ng 0 0
na siyang syndrome na nagpapahiwatig na walang mga error na natukoy ang tatlong qubit Pauli operasyon
ZZ identity at identity ZZ ay tinatawag na mga stabilizer generator para sa code na ito at ang stabilizer ng code ay ang set
na nabuo ng mga stabilizer generator ang set na ito ang stabilizer ay isang pundamental na mahalagang mathematical
na bagay na nauugnay sa code na ito at tatalakayin pa natin ang papel na ginagampanan nito habang nagpapatuloy ang aralin sa ngayon
ituturo ko lamang na maaari tayong gumawa ng ibang pagpipilian para sa mga generator halimbawa maaari tayong pumili ng Z identity Z kapalit ng alinman
sa mga generator na pinili natin at ang code at ang stabilizer ay magiging eksaktong pareho susunod ay isasaalang-alang natin ang bit flip
detection para sa three-bit repetition code na may focus sa mga interaksyon at relasyon sa pagitan ng mga Pauli
operasyon na kasangkot katuwiran ang mga stabilizer generator at ang mga error mismo ipagpalagay na nag-encode tayo ng isang
qubit gamit ang three-bit repetition code at nagaganap ang isang bit flip error sa pinakakaliwa na qubit ito ay nagdudulot ng ating estado Psi na maging
nagbago ayon sa aksyon ng isang X operasyon o X error sa pinakakaliwa na qubit tulad ng alam na natin maaari nating tuklasin
ang error na ito sa pamamagitan ng pagsasagawa ng mga parity check para sa three-bit repetition code o katumbas nito maaari nating sukatinin ang
encoding nang hindi nakakapinsala tinatrato ang mga stabilizer generator bilang mga observable magsimula tayo sa una
stabilizer generator at tingnan kung ano ang mangyayari ang ating estado ay naapektuhan ng isang X error at nais nating maunawaan
kung paano naiimpluwensyahan ng sukat ng stabilizer generator bilang isang observable ng error na ito ang x at z ay nagtatago samantalang
lahat ay nagko-commute sa identity Matrix at kaya sumusunod na ang ZZ identity ay nagtatago sa X identity
identity kaya nakakakuha tayo ng minus sign kapag napalitan ang pagkakasunod-sunod at alam din natin na ang ZZ identity ay hindi gumagawa ng anuman sa S
dahil ang S ay isang valid na encoding ng isang qubit at ang mga valid na encoding ay palaging plus isa na eigenvector ng parehong stabilizer
generator na nag-iiwan sa atin ng negatibong X identity identity na inilapat sa S at samakatuwid ang X identity identity na inilapat sa
S ay isang eigenvector ng ZZ identity na may eigenvalue negatibong isa maaari rin tayong gumawa ng katulad
sa ikalawang stabilizer generator ngunit sa pagkakataong ito ang error ay nagko-commute sa stabilizer generator at kaya ang ating
Corrupted State ay muli isang eigenvector ng stabilizer generator ngunit sa pagkakataong ito ang eigenvalue ay positibong
isa kaya ang ating Corrupted State ay isang eigenvector ng parehong stabilizer generator at ang eigenvalue ay plus isa o
minus isa ay natutukoy kung ang error ay nagko-commute o nagtatago sa bawat stabilizer generator para sa una
ang error at ang stabilizer generator ay nagtatago at para sa pangalawa ay nagko-commute ang mga ito at palagi itong magiging isa o ang isa pa dahil ang anumang dalawang
Pauli operasyon ay nagko-commute o nagtatago samantala ang aktwal na estado Psi ay hindi talaga gumaganap ng mahalagang
papel dito maliban sa katotohanang ang mga stabilizer generator ay kumikilos nang walang kabuluhan sa estado na ito kaya kapag iniisip natin ang
pag-detect ng mga error hindi talaga natin kailangang alalahanin ang partikular na encoded na estado ang mahalaga lamang ay kung ang error ay nagko-commute o nagtatago
sa bawat stabilizer generator kaya gumawa tayo ng talahanayan na may isang hilera para sa bawat stabilizer generator
at isang kolumn para sa bawat error dito ay isinama ko lamang ang mga error na naaayon sa isang bit flip
pati na rin ang walang error sa lahat na ipinahiwatig ng identity na naka-tensor sa sarili nito nang tatlong beses maaari tayong magdagdag ng higit pang mga kolumn para sa ibang mga error kung nais natin
ngunit sa ngayon ay magtutuon tayo sa mga error na ito lamang ang entry sa talahanayan ay alinman sa plus isa o minus isa depende sa
kung ang error at ang stabilizer generator ay nagko-commute o nagtatago kaya para sa bawat error sa talahanayan maaari nating tingnan
ang kaukulang kolumn upang makita kung paano babaguhin ng error na iyon ang anumang ibinigay na encoding sa isang plus isa o minus isa na eigenvector
ng bawat stabilizer generator ang mga kolum na ito ay naaayon nang eksakto sa syndrome na makukuha natin mula sa
mga parity check na katumbas ng mga hindi nakakasira na sukat ng mga stabilizer generator bilang
observable siyempre ang mga entry sa talahanayan na ito ay mga plus isa at minus isa sa halip na mga zero at isa ayon sa pagkakasunod-sunod
at kung mas gusto mo maaari mong isipin ang mga syndrome bilang mga kaukulang binary string sa halip na mga kolumn ng mga plus isa at minus isa ngunit mayroon
direktang katumbas at para lamang gawing mas malinaw at direkta ang koneksyon sa pagitan ng mga syndrome at ng mga eigenvalue
tutukuyin ko ang mga vector ng mga plus isa at minus isa na ito bilang mga syndrome tulad ng dati ang mga syndrome ay nagsasabi
sa atin ng isang bagay tungkol sa anumang error na naganap at sa partikular kung alam natin na isa sa apat na posibleng error na ito
ang naganap ang syndrome ay nagpapahiwatig sa atin kung alin ang nangyari at maaari nating itama ito sa pamamagitan ng muling paglapat ng error kung
pipiliin natin susunod ay magdadagdag ako ng kaunti pa tungkol sa mga syndrome at sa partikular ay mas malapit nating titingnan ang
kanilang mga algebraic na aspeto ang ating mga encoding ay tatlong qubit na estado kaya sila ay mga unit vector sa isang
walong dimensyonal na complex vector space at ang ginagawa ng apat na posibleng syndrome ay ang paghiwa ng walong dimensyonal na espasyong ito
sa apat na dalawang dimensyonal na subspace ibig sabihin ang mga vector sa alinman sa mga subspace na ito ay palagi magbibigay sa atin ng parehong
syndrome sa mas detalyado ang diagram na ito ay naglalarawan kung paano nahahati ang walong dimensyonal na espasyo
ang bawat stabilizer generator ay pinagghihiwalay ang espasyo sa dalawang subspace na may pantay na Dimension katuwiran ang espasyo ng plus isa na
eigenvector at ang espasyo ng minus isa na eigenvector halimbawa ang plus isa na eigenvector ng ZZ identity ay mga linear combination
ng mga standard basis state kung saan ang pinakakaliwa na dalawang bit ay may even parity at ang minus isa na eigenvector ay mga linear
combination ng mga standard basis state kung saan ang pinakakaliwa na dalawang bit ay may odd parity at ang sitwasyon ay katulad para sa
isa pang stabilizer generator maliban na ito ang pinaka-kanan na dalawang bit sa halip na pinakakaliwa na dalawang bit kaya madali ang paglalarawan sa apat na subspace na ito
sa kasong ito dahil ito ay napakasimpleng code sa partikular ang subspace
na naaayon sa syndrome plus isa plus isa ay ang espasyong sinaklaw ng ket 000 at ket 111 na siyang espasyo ng mga valid
encoding at iyon ay tinatawag na code space at sa pangkalahatan ang mga espasyo ay sinaklaw ng mga standard basis state
na ipinapakita sa kaukulang mga parisukat kahit hindi ito palaging malinaw o madaling makita ang mga syndrome
ay nagbabahagi rin ng lahat ng tatlong qubit Pauli operasyon na kumakatawan sa mga posibleng Pauli error na maaaring mangyari sa apat na pantay na koleksyon
depende sa kung aling syndrome ang magiging sanhi ng error na iyon halimbawa ang anumang Pauli operasyon
na nagko-commute sa parehong stabilizer generator ay nagbubunga ng syndrome plus1 plus1 at sa gitna ng 64 na posibleng tatlo
qubit Pauli operasyon ay eksaktong 16 ang nasa kategoryang ito kasama ang tatlong binanggit sa screen at katulad nito para sa ibang tatlo
syndrome hindi iyon halata ngunit totoo ito at ang pangunahing katangiang ito na ang mga syndrome ay nagbabahagi ng parehong state space
kung saan nabubuhay ang mga encoding at lahat ng posibleng Pauli error sa espasyo sa mga pantay na piraso ay isang bagay na
totoo sa pangkalahatan para sa mga stabilizer code na malapit na nating tukuyin nang eksakto bagaman ito ay halos isang aside lamang sa
puntong ito kapaki-pakinabang na banggitin na ang mga Pauli operasyon na nagko-commute sa parehong stabilizer generator o katumbas nito
mga Pauli operasyon na nagbubunga ng syndrome plus1 plus1 ngunit hindi sila mismo proporsyonal sa mga elemento ng stabilizer ay lumalabas na kumikilos tulad ng
mga single qubit Pauli operasyon sa The Logical qubit na na-encode natin halimbawa ang XXX ay nagko-commute sa
parehong stabilizer generator ngunit hindi ito proporsyonal sa anumang elemento ng stabilizer at sa katunayan malinaw kung
iisipin mo ang code na ito sandali na ang epekto ng operasyong ito sa isang encoding ay katumbas ng isang X gate sa
logical qubit na na-encode at muli ito ay isang bagay na naglalageneralize sa lahat ng stabilizer code ngayon ay panahon na para tukuyin ang stabilizer
codes sa pangkalahatan at ang paraan ng pagtatrabaho nito ay gumagawa tayo ng isang bagay na ganap na katulad ng tinalakay natin para sa
three-bit repetition code maliban na pumipili tayo ng ibang mga stabilizer generator na lahat ay tatawagin kong P1
hanggang PR para sa layunin ng paliwanag na ito ang mga stabilizer generator na ito ay dapat lahat ay maging N qubit Pauli operasyon
kung saan ang N ay ang bilang ng mga qubit na ginagamit para sa encoding at hindi natin maaaring basta pumili ng kahit anong set ng stabilizer generator sila
ay kailangang sumunod sa ilang mga pangunahing kondisyon una ang mga stabilizer generator ay DAPAT LAHAT nagko-commute sa isa't
isa sa kaso ng three-bit repetition code hindi natin binigyan ng atensyon ito ngunit madaling mapansin na ang ZZ identity at identity
ZZ ay nagko-commute talaga dahil nagko-commute ang Z sa sarili nito at lahat ng bagay ay nagko-commute sa
identity para sa mga stabilizer code na may mas kumplikadong stabilizer generator sa kabilang banda kasama ang mga code kung saan mayroon kaming
parehong X at Z na lumalabas sa mga stabilizer generator ito ay isang mahalagang kondisyon na kailangang
suriin ang isang paraan ng pag-iisip tungkol sa pangangailangan para sa kondisyong ito ay na tratrata natin ang mga stabilizer generator bilang mga observable at sa pamamagitan ng pag-aatas na
sila ay lahat nagko-commute tinitiyak natin na ang pagkakasunod-sunod ng ating pagsasagawa ng mga sukat ay hindi
mahalaga pangalawa ang mga stabilizer generator ay dapat bumuo ng isang tinatawag na minimal generating set na ibig sabihin kung aalisin natin ang alinman
sa kanila ay makakakuha tayo ng mas maliit na stabilizer at isang paraan ng pagpapahayag nito nang matematika ay ipinapakita dito sa
screen sa mahigpit na pagsasalita ang kondisyong ito ay hindi talaga mahalaga sa paraan ng pagtatrabaho ng isang stabilizer code sa operasyonal
na kahulugan at minsan ay may katuturan na pag-isipan ang mga non-minimal generating set tulad ng makikita natin sa susunod na aralin ngunit
para sa layunin ng pagsusuri ng mga stabilizer code at pagpapaliwanag ng kanilang mga katangian ay ipagpapalagay natin na ang kondisyong ito ay
nasa lugar ang kondisyong ito ay pangunahing nagtitiiyak na ang bawat observable na sinusukat natin upang makuha ang syndrome ay nagdaragdag
ng impormasyon tungkol sa mga posibleng error kumpara sa pagiging redundant at nagbibigay ng mga resulta na madaling mahihinuha mula sa ibang mga stabilizer generator bilang
mga observable at sa wakas ay dapat na ang kahit isang hindi-zero na vector ay naayos ng lahat
ng mga stabilizer generator at lumalabas na ito ay katumbas ng pag-aatas na ang -1 times identity sa N qubit ay hindi
nakapaloob sa stabilizer hindi iyon halata ngunit ang punto ay posible na pumili ng isang minimal generating
set ng N qubit Pauli operasyon na lahat nagko-commute sa isa't isa at gayon pa man walang vector na sabay-sabay na isang plus isa na
eigenvector ng lahat ng mga ito at hindi natin nais na alalahanin ang posibilidad na ito dahil ang mga code kung saan walang mga valid na encoding ay hindi
kawili-wili kaya iyon ang mga kinakailangan sa mga stabilizer generator para sa isang stabilizer code at kung mayroon tayong set ng mga generator na
nakakatugon sa mga kondisyong ito kung gayon mayroon tayong valid na stabilizer code at maaari nating isaalang-alang ang mga katangian nito mayroong marami
iba't ibang stabilizer code na may iba't ibang katangian na ginagawa silang kawili-wili o hindi ngunit silang lahat ay nakakatugon sa ilang pangunahing
katangian na katulad ng mga nakita na natin para sa three-bit repetition code
titingnan natin ang ilang halimbawa sa lalong madaling panahon ngunit bago iyon hayaan akong banggitin na kapag tinutukoy natin ang code space ng isang stabilizer code ang ibig natin ay ang subspace
ng N qubit state space na kinabibilangan ng bawat vector na sabay-sabay na isang plus isa na eigenvector ng bawat isa sa
mga stabilizer generator ito ang subspace ng N qubit state space kung saan nabubuhay ang mga valid na encoding at magkakaroon tayo ng higit na
sasabihin tungkol sa subspace na ito habang nagpapatuloy ang aralin ngayon tingnan natin ang ilang halimbawa ng mga stabilizer
code narito ang halimbawa na tinalakay na natin ang ordinary 3-bit repetition code at maaari rin nating ipahayag ang
binagong bersyon ng code na iyon mula sa nakaraang aralin na maaaring makita ang isang phase flip sa halip na isang bit flip bilang isang stabilizer code tulad ng ipinapakita
dito sa pagkakataong ito ang mga stabilizer generator ay sumusukat ng mga XX observable sa halip na mga ZZ observable kaya ang mga ito ay halos
mga parity check sa plus minus basis sa halip na standard basis sa parehong kaso maaari nating
agad makita na mayroon tayong valid na stabilizer code dahil nagko-commute ang mga stabilizer generator ang mga ito ay minimal
generating set at ang code space ay hindi trivial tulad ng alam na natin ngunit maaari rin nating malinaw na makita na hindi natin
mabubuo ang negatibong -1 times identity at narito ang 9 qubit Shore code na isa ring stabilizer code
na ipinahayag ng mga stabilizer generator sa kasong ito mayroon tayong halos tatlong kopya ng three-bit
repetition code isa para sa bawat isa sa tatlong bloke ng tatlong qubit pati na rin ang huling dalawang stabilizer generator na
may anyo na katulad ng circuit na nakita natin sa nakaraang aralin para sa pag-detect ng mga phase flip para sa
code na ito ang isa pang paraan ng pag-iisip tungkol sa huling dalawang stabilizer generator na ito ay na sila ay kumukuha ng eksaktong parehong anyo tulad ng
mayroon tayo para sa three-bit repetition code para sa mga phase flip maliban na pinapalitan natin ang XXX para sa X at ang dahilan para
doon ay na ang XXX ay naaayon sa isang X operasyon sa The Logical qubit na na-encode gamit ang 3-bit repetition code ngunit
iyon ay isang aside at hindi ito isang bagay na kailangang alalahanin ngayon kung sakaling hindi ito malinaw susunod ay titingnan natin ang ilang
karagdagang halimbawa ngunit bago iyon hayaan akong banggitin na ang mga tao ay madalas na nag-iilabas ng mga tensor product symbol kapag naglalarawan ng mga stabilizer code dahil ito ay karaniwang
nagpapadali ng pagbabasa kaya narito ang hitsura ng mga code na ito nang walang mga tensor product symbol
ngunit siyempre ang mga ito ay mga tensor product at hindi mga ordinary na matrix product halimbawa iniilabas lamang natin ang mga tensor product symbol upang mas mababa
ng kalat at mas malinaw ang mga pattern narito ang isa pang halimbawa ito ay tinatawag
na 7 qubit Steane code at ito ay may ilang kahanga-hangang katangian babalik tayo sa isang ito
paminsan-minsan sa natitirang mga aralin ng yunit ngunit sa ngayon ay maaari lang nating i-verify na ito ay isang valid na stabilizer
code sa partikular ang unang tatlong stabilizer generator ay malinaw na nagko-commute sa isa't isa dahil nagko-commute ang Z sa
sarili nito at nagko-commute ang identity sa lahat ng bagay at ang sitwasyon ay katulad para sa huling tatlo kaya nananatili
na suriin na kung kukuha tayo ng isa sa Z stabilizer generator at isa sa X stabilizer generator ay nagko-commute ang mga ito
at madali itong siyasatin sa pamamagitan ng siyam na posibleng pairings upang suriin na sa lahat ng kasong ito ay palagi
tayong magkakaroon ng isang X at isang Z na nagkakatugma sa parehong posisyon ng even number ng beses kaya ang dalawang generator ay magko-commute tulad
ng nagko-commute ang XX at ZZ ito ay isang minimal generating set at ito ay may hindi trivial na code space ngunit
hindi ko susubukang argumentahin iyon sa video na ito at sa halip ay iiiwan ko iyon para sa iyong pag-iisipan kung nais mo ang 7 qubit Steane code ay katulad
sa 9 qubit Shore code sa kahulugan na ito ay nag-encode ng isang qubit at nagbibigay-daan sa pagwawasto ng isang arbitrary na error sa isang qubit ngunit ito ay nangangailangan lamang
ng pitong qubit sa halip na siyam hindi iyon ang pinakamaliit na bilang ng qubit na kinakailangan para sa isang error correcting code upang
mag-encode ng isang qubit at magtama para sa isang arbitrary na error sa isang qubit narito ang isang stabilizer code na
karaniwang tinatawag na five qubit code na nag-encode din ng isang qubit at maaaring magtama ng isang arbitrary na single qubit error
at ang lima ang pinakamaliit na bilang ng qubit para saan ito posible narito ang isa pang halimbawa ng isang
stabilizer code kahit na ito ay hindi talaga isang code sa mahigpit na kahulugan dahil ang code space ay
isang-dimensyonal sa partikular ang code space para sa code na ito ay ang espasyong sinaklaw ng isang ebit o sa madaling salita ay isang phi plus
Bell state kaya hindi mo talagang ma-encode ang anumang qubit gamit ang code na ito ngunit ito ay isang valid pa ring stabilizer code kung saan ang code
space ay isang-dimensyonal at posible na gumawa ng katulad para sa isang GHZ
state kaya iyon ang ilang halimbawa ng mga stabilizer code at makikita natin ang napakaraming karagdagang halimbawa sa
susunod na aralin ipagpalagay na binibigyan tayo ng isang stabilizer code ang isang natural na tanong na itatanong tungkol dito
marahil ang una mismong tanong na pumapasok sa isip ay kung ilang qubit ang ini-encode nito may napakasimpleng sagot ang tanong na iyon
at upang maipaliwanag ito maging tiyak tayo tungkol sa stabilizer code na pinag-uusapan mayroon tayong R N qubit
stabilizer generator P1 hanggang Pr na nakakatugon sa tatlong kinakailangan na binanggit ko kanina katuwiran ang
mga stabilizer generator ay lahat nagko-commute sa isa't isa ito ay isang minimal generating set kaya hindi natin matatanggap ang parehong
stabilizer kung aalisin natin ang isa sa mga generator at mayroon kahit isa na hindi-zero na vector sa code
space tulad ng ipinakita ng theorem na ipinapakita sa screen ay dapat na kung gayon ang code space ng stabilizer code ay may
Dimension 2 ^ N minus R o ang isa pang paraan ng pagsasabi niyon ay maaari tayong mag-encode ng N
minus R qubit gamit ang code na ito kaya kung tutuusin mayroon tayong N qubit sa ating mga encoding at ang bawat isa
stabilizer generator ay epektibong nag-aalis ng isang qubit sa mga tuntunin ng ilang qubit ang maaari nating i-encode
ang theorem na ito ay hindi masyadong mahirap patunayan at ipapakita ko sa inyo ang isang patunay sa lalong madaling panahon ngunit una titingnan natin ang ilang
halimbawa simula sa ordinary 3-bit repetition code mayroon tayong tatlong qubit sa ating mga
encoding kaya ang N ay katumbas ng tatlo at mayroon na R katumbas ng 2 stabilizer generator at kaya maaari tayong mag-encode ng isa
qubit gamit ang code na ito pansinin na hindi ito tungkol sa kung aling o ilang error ang maaaring matuklasin o
maitama iyon ay ibang bagay ito ay isang pahayag lamang tungkol sa dimension ng code
space para sa isa pang halimbawa isaalang-alang ang 5 qubit code dito mayroon tayong limang qubit at apat
stabilizer generator kaya muli ang code space ay may Dimension na dalawa na ibig sabihin maaari tayong mag-encode ng isang qubit gamit ang
code at isang halimbawa pa para sa ngayon para sa ebit stabilizer code mayroon tayong dalawang qubit at dalawang stabilizer generator kaya
ang code space ay isang-dimensyonal at tulad ng binanggit ko kanina ito ang espasyong sinaklaw ng phi plus Bell State
makikita natin ang higit pang mga halimbawa habang nagpapatuloy tayo kasama ang mga code kung saan maaari tayong mag-encode ng higit sa isang qubit ngunit sa ngayon
tingnan natin kung paano natin mapapatunayan ang theorem ang unang bagay na kailangan nating mapansin ay dahil ang mga stabilizer
generator ay nagko-commute at bumubuo ng isang minimal generating set at dahil ang bawat Pauli operasyon ay sariling inverse bawat
elemento ng stabilizer ay maaaring maipahayag nang natatangi bilang isang produkto kung saan itataas natin ang bawat stabilizer generator
PK sa kapangyarihan ng AK kung saan ang bawat AK ay alinman sa Z o isa at pagkatapos ay i-multiply natin ang mga resulta
nang magkasama ang isa pang paraan ng pagsasabi nito ay nakukuha natin ang bawat elemento ng stabilizer sa pamamagitan ng pagpaparami ng ilang subset ng
mga stabilizer generator nang magkasama at hindi tayo makakakuha ng parehong stabilizer element mula sa magkaibang mga subset at isang bagay na
nagpapahiwatig nito ay ang tanging paraan upang ipahayag ang N qubit identity operation sa ganitong paraan ay ang lahat ng kapangyarihan ay
zero susunod tukuyin natin ang pi K bilang ang projection onto the plus one eigespace ng PK para sa bawat K mula 1 hanggang R at mayroon
itong simpleng formula para sa projection na ito maaari nating i-average lang ang PK sa identity sa N qubit na epektibong nag-iiwan ng
plus isa na eigenvalue nang mag-isa at inililipat ang lahat ng minus isa na eigenvalue sa zero
values ngayon ang code space ay tinukoy bilang ang set ng lahat ng vector na sabay-sabay na plus isa eigenvector ng lahat
ng mga stabilizer generator dahil nagko-commute ang mga stabilizer generator ang mga projection ay dapat ding nagko-commute at
nagpapahiwatig ito na ang produkto ng mga projection na ito ay isa ring projection at sa partikular ito ang projection onto the
intersection ng mga subspace na ang mga indibidwal na projection ay nag-project onto o sa madaling salita ito ang projection onto the
code space maaari nating palawakin ang produkto na ito at ang makukuha natin ay ang average ng bawat
elemento ng stabilizer at sa wakas dahil ang dimension ng anumang subspace ay katumbas ng
trace ng projection onto that subspace nakita natin na ang dimension ng code space ay ang average ng mga trace ng mga elemento ng
stabilizer ngunit maliban sa N qubit identity operation ang lahat ng elemento ng stabilizer ay dapat magkaroon ng
Trace na katumbas ng zero dahil ang tatlong non-identity Pauli matrix ay lahat ay may Trace na katumbas ng zero ang trace ng N qubit identity
operation ay 2 to the N at kaya nakita natin na ang dimension ng code space ay 2 to the N minus R na nagpapatunay ng
theorem susunod ay magdadagdag ako ng kaunti tungkol sa kung paano maaaring ma-encode ang mga qubit gamit ang mga stabilizer code ngunit para magawa iyon
kailangan muna nating ipakilala ang mga Clifford operation ang mga Clifford operation ay mga unitary na operasyon sa anumang bilang ng
qubit na maaaring maipatupad ng mga Quantum circuit na may limitadong set ng mga gate katuwiran ang Hadamard gate S gate
at controlled not gate pansinin na ang mga T gate ay hindi kasama ni ang mga Toffoli gate o Fredkin
gate at hindi lamang ang mga gate na iyon ay hindi kasama sa listahang ito kundi sa katunayan ay hindi posible na maipatupad ang mga gate na iyon
gamit ang mga nakalista dito kaya hindi sila mga Clifford operation ang mga Pauli operasyon sa kabilang banda
ay mga Clifford operation at partikular na maaaring ipatupad ang mga ito gamit ang mga sequence ng Hadamard at S
gate kaya iyon ang simpleng paraan upang tukuyin ang mga Clifford operation ngunit hindi talaga nito ipinaliwanag kung bakit sila tinukoy sa
ganitong paraan o kung ano ang espesyal tungkol sa partikular na koleksyon ng mga gate na ito narito ang tunay na dahilan kung bakit tinukoy ang mga Clifford operation tulad ng
ito hanggang sa isang global phase ang mga N qubit Clifford operation ay eksaktong ang mga unitary
na operasyon na palaging nagbabago ng mga Pauli operasyon sa mga Pauli operasyon sa pamamagitan ng conjugation upang maging mas tiyak ang isang N qubit
unitary operation U ay isang Clifford operation hanggang sa isang global phase factor kung at tanging kung para sa bawat N qubit Pauli
operasyon ang pag-conjugate ng Pauli operasyong iyon ng U ay nagbibigay sa atin ng plus o minus isa times ilang posibleng iba't ibang N
qubit Pauli operasyon madali mong masusuri na ang katangiang ito ay totoo para sa mga Hadamard gate S
gate at CNOT gate kaya ito ay kinakailangan na nananatili para sa mga circuit na binuo mula sa mga gate na ito ang mas mahirap patunayan ay
na ito ay pumupunta sa kabilang direksyon na kung binibigyan tayo ng isang partikular na N qubit unitary operation U na nakakatugon sa
katangiang ito kung gayon dapat itong posible na maipatupad ito hanggang sa isang global phase gamit lamang ang Hadamard S at CNOT
gate hindi ko tathakayin ang patunay ng implikasyong iyon ngunit ito ay totoo at maaari mo itong hanapin kung
interesado ka ang mga Clifford operation ay hindi Universal para sa Quantum computation ibig sabihin hindi natin maaaring patakbuhin ang mga arbitrary
Quantum computation gamit lamang ang Hadamard S at CNOT gate sa katunayan para sa isang ibinigay na halaga ng N mayroon lamang finite na bilang ng
N qubit Clifford operation kaya ito ay discrete na set ng mga operasyon kaya kakaiba sa isang
universal na set ng mga Quantum gate hindi natin maaaring i-approximate ang mga arbitrary na unitary operation sa anumang ninanais na antas ng katumpakan at sa
katunayan ang pagsasagawa ng mga Clifford operation sa mga standard basis state na sinusundan ng mga standard basis measurement ay hindi makakapagbigay-daan
sa atin na magsagawa ng mga computation na nasa labas ng kakayahan ng mga classical algorithm dahil maaari nating mahusay na i-simulate ang mga computation ng form na ito
nang klasikal ang katotohanang ito ay kilala bilang Gottesman-Knill theorem at ang standard na patunay ng theorem na iyon ay sa ilang kahulugan
batay sa stabilizer formalism sa partikular ang paraan ng pagtatrabaho nito ay maaari nating subaybayan ang paraan ng pag-transform ng mga Clifford operation ng mga Pauli
operasyon sa pamamagitan ng conjugation na maaaring gawin nang mahusay at pagkatapos ay hinuhulaan mula doon kung ano ang ginagawa ng mga computation sa
mga qubit kaya ano ang kinalaman nito sa mga stabilizer code well ang isang stabilizer code ay nagbibigay sa atin
ng isang code space ng isang tiyak na Dimension at mayroon tayong kalayaang gamitin ang code space na iyon sa anumang paraan na gusto natin kaya wala kang pwersang mag-encode ng
mga qubit sa espasyong iyon sa isang tiyak na paraan ngunit palaging magiging posible na isagawa ang isang encoding gamit ang isang Clifford operation
bilang encoder na maganda dahil ang mga Clifford operation ay medyo simple kumpara sa mga arbitrary na unitary
operasyon mayroong mga paraan upang i-optimize ang kanilang implementasyon na gumagana kasunod ng katulad na linya sa patunay ng Gottesman
Knill theorem at bilang resulta ang mga circuit para sa pagpapatupad ng mga ito ay hindi kailangang maging malaki
sa partikular ay palagi nating maisasagawa ang isang encoding gamit ang isang Clifford operation na nangangailangan ng kaunti pa sa isang quadratic na bilang ng mga gate
dahil ito ay totoo naman sa bawat Clifford operation kaya ang resulta ay na para sa isang ibinigay na stabilizer code ay palagi
itong posible na mahusay na i-encode ang mga qubit gamit ang code na iyon at ang mga mathematical na kasangkapan na kapaki-pakinabang para sa pag-unawa ng mga Clifford operation ay makakatulong sa
proseso halimbawa narito ang isang encoder para sa 7 qubit Steane code ito ay isang Clifford operation at lumalabas na
ang isa ay hindi man lang nangangailangan ng S gate para sa mga pangkalahatang stabilizer code ang pag-detect ng error ay gumagana sa sumusunod
na paraan tulad ng dati ay ipagpalagay natin na mayroon tayong N qubit stabilizer generator P1 hanggang Pr at hayaan nating E ang isang N qubit Pauli
operasyon na kumakatawan sa isang hypothetical na error sa isang encoding isinasaalang-alang lamang natin ang mga Pauli
operasyon bilang mga error sa paraan ng discretization ng mga error na gumagana sa parehong paraan para sa mga arbitrary na stabilizer code tulad ng ginagawa nito para sa 9 qubit Shore
code ang paraan ng ating pagsuri ng mga error ay ang pagsukat ng bawat isa sa mga stabilizer generator bilang
mga observable mayroon R stabilizer generator kaya nangangahulugan ito ng R na resulta kung saan ang bawat isa ay plus isa o minus isa
o isang binary na halaga kung mas gusto mong iugnay ang zero sa plus isa at isa sa minus isa at ang R resulta
na ito nang magkasama ang bumubuo ng syndrome tulad ng mayroon tayo para sa three-bit repetition code noong ang R ay katumbas ng
dalawa sa pangkalahatan ay may tatlong posibleng kaso para sa error E sa mga tuntunin ng pag-detect nito at sila ay ang mga sumusunod una
maaaring ang E ay nasa stabilizer ibig sabihin posible na mabuo ang E mula sa mga stabilizer generator o
bahagyang mas pangkalahatan ay maaaring ang E ay katumbas ng isang stabilizer element hanggang sa isang global
phase sa kasong ito ang E ay hindi talaga isang error dahil wala itong epekto sa code space maliban sa posibleng
pag-inject ng isang global phase na walang epekto kaya hindi na natin kailangang alalahanin ang mga error tulad nito anuman ang
hindi trivial na aksyon na maaari nitong gawin ay nangyayari sa labas ng code space kaya hindi tayo nababahala
ang mas malaking alalahanin ay ang posibilidad na ang E ay wala sa stabilizer kahit hanggang sa isang global phase ngunit
gayon pa man ito ay nagko-commute sa bawat isa sa ating mga stabilizer generator alalahanin na ang
anti-commutation ng error sa isang stabilizer generator ang nagdudulot ng isang minus isa na lumabas sa isang lugar sa syndrome
ngunit hindi iyon nangyayari sa kasong ito kaya ito ay isang error na tunay na nagbabago ng mga vector sa code space sa ilang
hindi trivial na paraan at alam natin ito dahil kung hindi ay ito ay magiging proporsyonal sa isang stabilizer element ngunit ito ay
hindi natutukoy ng code kaya ito ang masamang kaso mayroon tayong error na posibleng nagbabago ng
anumang Quantum na impormasyon na na-encode natin ngunit ang code ay hindi alam ang katotohanang ito halimbawa para sa three-bit
repetition code ang XXX ay nasa kategoryang ito at ang huling posibilidad ay ang E
ay nagtatago sa kahit isa sa mga stabilizer generator at ibig sabihin nito na natutukoy ng code ang error na ito dahil
makakakuha tayo ng syndrome na may kahit isa na minus isa sa isang lugar nito na nagpapahiwatig na may mali at kailangan nating subukang itama ang error na ito
sa anumang paraan kaya iyon ang mga posibilidad bilang isang terminolohiya
kapag tinutukoy natin ang distance ng isang stabilizer code ang ibig natin ay ang minimum weight ng isang Pauli operasyon na nahuhulog
sa ikalawang kategorya ibig sabihin nagbabago ito ng code space sa ilang hindi trivial na paraan ngunit ang code ay hindi
nakakadetekta nito at kapag sinabi nating ang isang stabilizer code ay isang [[N,M,D]] stabilizer code gamit ang
double square brackets tulad ng ipinapakita sa screen ang ibig sabihin noon ay ang mga encoding ay N qubit ang haba ang
code ay may kakayahang mag-encode ng M qubit kaya ang code space ay may Dimension 2 to the M at ang distance nito ay D kaya ang isang error ay kailangang magkaroon ng
weight na D o higit pa upang baguhin ang logical na estado ng anumang qubit na na-encode natin nang hindi natutukoy bilang isang
error titingnan na natin ngayon ang 7 qubit Steane code bilang isang halimbawa at tutukuyin natin kung ano ang distance
nito narito ang mga stabilizer generator para sa code na ito at alalahanin na ang distance ay ang minimum weight ng isang
N qubit Pauli operasyon na nagko-commute sa lahat ng mga stabilizer generator ngunit hindi mismo nasa stabilizer ni
proporsyonal sa isang elemento ng stabilizer ang tutukuyin natin ay na ang code na ito ay may distance
na tatlo ang paraan ng ating pagtutukoy nito ay ang una ay isaalang-alang ang anumang Pauli operasyon na may weight na pinakamataas na dalawa at
makikita natin na ang tanging paraan upang maaari itong mag-commute sa lahat ng anim na stabilizer generator ay ang maging identity na palaging isang elemento ng
stabilizer kaya ipagpalagay nating ang mga posibleng non-identity Pauli matrix na bumubuo ng operasyong ito na tatawagin nating
P at Q ay lumalabas sa pinakakaliwa na dalawang posisyon ito ay isang kaso lamang at kailangan nating
isaalang-alang ang lahat ng iba pang posibleng lokasyon para sa mga posibleng non-identity Pauli matrix na ito ngunit ang argumento ay halos kapareho para sa lahat
ng posibleng lokasyon well sa pagpapalagay ay nagko-commute ang operasyong ito sa lahat ng anim
stabilizer generator kaya sa partikular nagko-commute ito sa isa ito at nagko-commute din ito sa isa
ito ang Q ay naka-align sa identity Matrix sa parehong generator na kung kaya pinili natin ang dalawa at mayroon tayong identity
Matrix sa pinaka-kanan na limang posisyon ng error na ito at kaya nakita natin na ang P ay dapat nagko-commute sa parehong X
at Z dahil kung hindi ay magtatago ang error na ito sa isa sa dalawang generator na ito ngunit ang tanging Pauli matrix na
nagko-commute sa parehong X at Z ay ang identity kaya ang P ay dapat identity at ngayon na alam na natin iyon
maaari tayong pumili ng dalawa pang stabilizer generator na may X at Z sa pangalawang posisyon mula sa kaliwa at maaari
tayong gumawa ng katulad na konklusyon tungkol sa Q kaya walang paraan para sa isang weight na pinakamataas na 2 na error na makaiwas sa pag-detect ng code na ito
maliban kung ito ay ang identity operation lamang na nasa stabilizer kaya ito ay hindi talaga isang
error sa kabilang banda mayroon itong tatlong Pauli operasyon na nagko-commute sa lahat ng anim na stabilizer generator na ito
ngunit hindi proporsyonal sa mga stabilizer element at narito ang dalawang halimbawa kaya nakita natin na ang
code na ito ay may distance na tatlo ang huling bagay na tatalakayin natin sa araling ito ay ang pagwawasto ng mga error para sa
mga stabilizer code tulad ng dati ay ipagpalagay natin na ang ating code ay tinukoy ng N qubit stabilizer generator
P1 hanggang Pr at magsimula tayo sa pag-iisip ng kaunti tungkol sa lahat ng posibleng error na maaaring mangyari
mayroon 2 to the R na posibleng syndrome at tulad ng binanggit ko kanina sa aralin ang mga syndrome na ito ay nagbabahagi ng lahat
ng posibleng N qubit Pauli operasyon sa pantay na laking koleksyon kaya nangangahulugan iyon ng 4 to the N divided by 2 to the R Pauli operasyon
sa loob ng bawat set kaya kapag nakita natin ang isang partikular na syndrome maaaring ang alinman sa mga error na 4 to the N divided by 2
to the R ay responsable labis tayong binibilang nang kaunti dito kahit na dahil ang ilan sa mga
error na ito ay may eksaktong parehong epekto sa code space sa partikular kung mayroon tayong error E at i-multiply natin ang E sa anumang
stabilizer element S ay makakakuha tayo ng isa pang error na may eksaktong parehong epekto sa code space tulad ng E kaya
ang mga ito ay katumbas na mga error ang stabilizer ay may dalawa to the R na elemento at kung isasaalang-alang natin ito ay makikita natin
na para sa bawat syndrome ay mayroon 4 to the N minus R na magkakaparehong klase ng mga error na maaaring nagdulot ng syndrome na iyon
at ang ibig sabihin nito ay maliban kung ang R ay katumbas ng N kung saan mayroon tayong isang-dimensyonal na code space at
samakatuwid ay hindi makakapag-encode ng anumang qubit sa lahat ay hindi magiging posible na itama ang bawat error na maaari nating matuklasin sa halip
ang kailangan nating gawin ay pumili ng isang pagwawasto na operasyon lamang para sa bawat syndrome sa pag-asa na maitatama lamang ang isang klase ng katumbas na
mga error kaya paano natin dapat piliin kung anong pagwawasto ang isasagawa para sa bawat syndrome ang isang natural na estratehiya ay pumili ng
pinakamababang weight Pauli operasyon na nagdudulot ng anumang syndrome na sinusukat natin na may ideyang ang mas mababang weight Pauli
operasyon ay kumakatawan sa mga mas malamang na paliwanag para sa syndrome na iyon maaaring hindi ito ang
kaso para sa ilang noise model at ang isa pang natural na estratehiya ay ang anumang paraan ay kalkulahin ang pinaka-malamang na error na nagdudulot ng
ibinigay na syndrome ngunit sa ngayon ay isasaalang-alang lamang natin ang estratehiya kung saan sinusubukan nating itama ang mga error sa pamamagitan ng pagpili ng pinakamababang weight Pauli operasyon na nagdudulot ng
syndrome para sa isang distance D stabilizer code ang estratehiyang ito ay palagi magbibigay-daan sa atin na itama ang mga error na may weight nang mahigpit
na mas mababa sa kalahati ng D o sa madaling salita ang weight na pinakamataas na D minus 1 divided by 2 at ipapaliwanag ko nang maikli kung bakit ito
ay ipapakita nito halimbawa na ang 7 qubit Steane code ay makakapagtama ng anumang weight isa na Pauli error at sa pamamagitan ng
discretization ng mga error ibig sabihin nito na tulad ng 9 qubit Shore code ang Steane code ay makakapagtama ng isang arbitrary
error sa isang qubit kaya narito kung paano gumagana ito isaalang-alang na ang bilog na ito ay kumakatawan sa lahat ng posibleng Pauli
operasyon na nagbubunga ng all plus1 syndrome na siyang syndrome na nagmumungkahi na walang mga error na naganap
at walang mali sa gitna ng mga operasyong ito ay mayroon tayong mga elemento ng stabilizer o talagang
mga operasyon na proporsyonal sa mga elemento ng stabilizer at mayroon din tayong mga hindi trivial na error na nagbabago ng code space sa anumang paraan ngunit sila ay hindi
natutukoy ng code at alam natin sa kahulugan ng distance na ang bawat Pauli operasyon sa kategoryang ito ay dapat magkaroon ng weight na hindi bababa sa
D dahil ang D ay tinukoy bilang ang minimum weight ng mga operasyong ito mayroon din tayong mga Pauli operasyon
na nagdudulot ng iba pang mga syndrome na lumabas at maaari nating isaalang-alang ang bawat syndrome nang isa-isa kung nais natin ngunit dito ay nag-iisip lang tayo na
ang isang syndrome S ay lumabas ngayon isipin na ang E ay isang error sa kategoryang ito
na may weight nang mahigpit na mas mababa sa kalahati ng distance D well hindi natin alam na ito ang
kinakailangang minimum weight Pauli operasyon sa bilog na ito kaya kunin natin si C bilang ang minimum weight na operasyon sa set na ito o isa sa kanila kung mayroon
ng tie kaya maaaring ang C ay katumbas ng E o posibleng hindi ngunit dahil ang C ay may
minimum weight alam natin na hindi ito posibleng magkaroon ng weight na mas malaki kaysa sa weight ng E dahil ang C ay nasa set din
at ito ay may minimal na weight kaya ang correction operation C ay dapat magkaroon ng weight nang mahigpit na mas mababa sa kalahati ng
D kaya ano ang mangyayari kung ilapat natin ang correction C na ito sa anumang magiging estado natin pagkatapos ng error E
ang sagot ay na ang estado na makukuha natin ay C * e na pinarami sa original na encoding dahil una
ay pinarami natin ng E iyon ang error at pagkatapos ay pinarami natin ng C upang subukang itama ito at ang produktong ito ay dapat nasa
stabilizer o proporsyonal sa isang elemento ng stabilizer at narito kung bakit una dahil ang E at C ay nagbibigay sa atin ng
parehong syndrome ang C * E ay dapat magbigay sa atin ng all plus one syndrome dahil para sa isang ibinigay na
stabilizer generator alinman sa C at E parehong nagko-commute sa generator na iyon o parehong nagtatago ito ay dapat na pareho para sa
parehong dahil ang mga syndrome ay pareho at kung iisipin mo iyon sandali ay nagpapahiwatig ito na ang C * E ay dapat
nagko-commute sa lahat ng stabilizer generator at sa wakas ang C * E ay dapat
nasa stabilizer dahil ang weight nito ay hindi maaaring mas malaki kaysa sa kabuuan ng mga weight ng C at E at kaya ang weight nito
ay nang mahigpit na mas mababa sa D at ibig sabihin nito ay matagumpay nating natama ang E dahil ang paglapat ng E na sinundan ng C ay walang ginagawa sa
code space kaya iyon ay magaling ngunit mayroon lamang isang problema at iyon ay para sa mga stabilizer
code sa pangkalahatan ito ay isang computationally mahirap na problema na kalkulahin ang pinakamababang weight na operasyon na nagdudulot ng isang ibinigay
syndrome at sa katunayan ito ay totoo kahit para sa mga classical code na sa kontekstong ito maaari nating isipin bilang mga stabilizer code
kung saan mayroon lamang tayong mga identity matrix at Pauli Z matrix na lumalabas bilang mga tensor factor sa loob ng mga stabilizer
generator kaya kakaiba sa encoding step ang mga Clifford operation ay hindi dumarating upang iligtas tayo sa pagkakataong ito at ang tanging makatwirang
solusyon ay ang pumili ng mga partikular na code para saan ang magagandang pagwawasto ay maaaring kalkulahin nang mahusay at walang recipe para sa
ito sa simpleng salita ang pagbuo ng mga stabilizer code tulad nito ay bahagi ng artistry
ng Quantum code design at iyon ang magandang lugar upang tumigil para sa araling ito umaasa ako na sasama ka sa akin
sa susunod na aralin kung saan titingnan natin ang ilang partikular na Quantum code construction kasama ang mga code na naglalarawan ng artistry ng Quantum code
design sa isang kahanga-hangang paraan paalam sa ngayon